new faces of westminster calling time on
an alleged culture of fear and
intimidation in the tory party
angus mcvein and henry dixon-clegg wrote
a letter to boris johnson calling on the
government to take action to protect
those working in parliament we're
calling for a change partly in the
culture but also uh the fact that
these major allegations fly around as
just may gossip
and we thought that something had to be
said and we thought the staffers need a
voice this is our workplace as well and
we also wanted to create an environment
where colleagues can feel comfortable to
speak up
about experiences that they've had
in the letter it said staffers were
ashamed of parliament's reputation and
that sexual abuse harassment and
bullying have started to become
synonymous with politics
they then go on to say that major
allegations of illegal behavior are
treated as mere gossip and that a
culture of indifference and fear were
the root cause of abuse in parliament
but they say fellow staffers were
pressured by conservative campaign
headquarters not to sign the letter and
were told there would be a black mark
next to their name if they did so how
many staffers do you roughly reckon were
put off signing the letter i couldn't
put a number on it but there are a
significant amount of staffers that say
messaged us or spoke to us in person who
said that they weren't comfortable with
signing the letter but they agreed with
the contents of it we can't give you an
exact number but i'd say perhaps of the
people we did ask i'd say maybe 60 to 70
of people
in exchanges exclusively seen by sky
news conservative campaign headquarters
were said to be petrified at the
prospect of the letter the letter these
two staffers sent to boris johnson opens
up wider questions about the culture
here in westminster and emanating from
the top of the tory party and if
staffers are feeling pressured not to
speak out by senior tory figures then
what does that say about westminster as
a workplace
a spokesperson for the chief whip said
they have met with the staffers that
wrote the letter and offered to work
with them to ensure they were looked
after
but senior conservative mps told sky
news there are countless tales of mps
bullying their staff a problem which
they say desperately needs addressing we
do believe that the conservative party
can be a force for good in british
politics but as long as these rumors fly
around
and as long as the individuals in the
rumors are not uh are not addressed in
an appropriate and legal manner
the conservative party will always have
this this this issue
westminster has been saturated with
allegations of sleaze affecting all
political parties for henry and angus
this letter is the hopeful beginning of
some much needed change
mari aurora sky news westminster